.
In this presentation I want to give you an example of what
It means matching information for the line
Instead of making a traditional display using
Writing panel, I will use Excel program even
You can see how to do this yourself, if you have
Excel or any other program dealing with tables
We will not use mathematics with it
I just want you to realize
What it means to match information is with font, or action
Linear regression
So here, let's read the matter
The following table shows California's average income
- Remember, it's average, average California income -
From 1995 to 2002, he said
US Bureau of Statistics
Draw a graphic representation and find the equation
What you expect to be an average annual income
For the Californian family in 2010?
What are the meanings of slope and y intersection
In this matter?
If the first thing you do - you've copied and
Paste the image - we have to get the information in a way
Bring them to the table
Let's make some tables here
Let's set the years from 1995
This first column
Let us expand it further
Let me put the average income
This is the average family income in California
If we start from one year, or even 0 years
1995, 0, 1, 2, 3, 4
In fact if you want, I'll find the direction if
You continue to go down
I will find that the increase is by 1
Then income, I will copy
To prepare here
$ 53,807, $ 55,217, $ 55,209, $ 55,415 $ 63,100
$ 63,206, $ 63,761 then we have $ 65,766
If I need this here
I'll get rid of them
I can erase them
Let me make sure I have enough numbers
These are 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, and I have 1, 2, 3, 4, 5
6, 7, 8 numbers
I want to make sure I got the information correctly. $ 53,807, $ 55,217
$ 55,209, 415, 100, 206, 761, 766
Well, we'll start
Now we will find it in Excel program
Incredible ease if you know what you are pressuring
First, you set this information, you create a table, and then
Better, you create a decline for this information
If all you have to do is choose the information
Then go to the Insert button, and I will
Include the graph option
Then you can choose
Different types of graphs
I want to visualize the data
We will start
He has set the data
let's go
If you go with this actual income, it is
Year starting from 1995
If 1995
It was $ 53,807
In 1996 it was $ 55,217
He has set all the data
What I want to do now is to fit the line
This is not exactly a mistake
But let's see, if we assume that the line can represent this
The information is fine, I will make the Excel program suit the font
What I can have is all these options
In order to fit the font in different ways, all
These options are different
I want to choose this
Maybe you can not see it
It appears as a line between points
It also has an FX where it illustrates my equation
This line
If you click on it, we will start
It not only fits, but renames the data itself
On a different chart
Let me be a little arrogant
.
No, not to this degree
Let me make it a little bigger
We can cover the data now, because I think we know
what happens
Let me cover it that way
It does not just assign multiple data points, it's
In fact it fits the line with that data and gives me
Equation of that line
.
Let me see if I can zoom in a bit
I'll move it away so you can read it at least
He explains, that equation is this
The line is y = 1,882.3x + 52,847
If you remember what we know about the inclination
The intersection of y, the intersection of y is 52,847, which is, if
This line was used as a scale, where this line intersects on
General 0, or 1995
If you use this font as a model, in 1995 the line
It would be $ 52,847
Actual data were a bit out of this
They were slightly higher, $ 53,807
It was slightly higher
But we try to get as close a line as possible
Of all such data
He tries to minimize the distance
Space box, between each of these points
In line
We will not go into math here
But it gives us this beautiful equation
Now we can use this equation to expect things
If we say this is a good data model - let me know
Drop this down a bit - let's try
The answer to the question
So we've drawn a graphic representation here - in fact Excel has done it
We have created the equation here
The question now is, what do you expect to be an average annual income
For the California family in 2010?
If here, we can use the equation given to us
This was in 2002
I can write the year
And 2010 is about 8 years later
Let me put a pole here
.
These years 1995, 1996
Then the excel program will be able to generate it if you choose these
I went to this little button and I get off
Down, the Excel program is already able to find out I want to
Insert one year at a time
If I say the years of 1995, again I can continue
In this direction here
If until 2010 it has been 15 years
We can apply this equation
Can say that will equal, relative to this
The font - I will read it here, I hope you can read
What I'm saying - 1,882.3 x x
x Here are the years from 1995
I can select this box, or I can type
Number 15 inside
This means × this box, ie x 15
Then + 52,847, + this
Press the OK button and the prediction is $ 81,081.50
If you complete this line for another 8 years
Will expect the average income in California
Per family would be $ 81,000
Anyway, I hope you found this presentation enjoyable
The tables are very useful tools
I will give you the meaning of why linear models are considered interesting
Why fonts are important, and how you can use them
The tools for interpreting data are probably some conclusion
I am the expectations
This conclusion is using
Linear regression
.